what's going on my boy trending lockhart
in the building what's good what's good
what's good how are you doing all these
lsu guys they're going to start calling
it leo frost tent university of frost
state university man what's going on
y'all i'm leo frost i'm the youngest
jeweler in the game i'm your favorite
athlete's favorite jeweler it costs a
frost and you're watching gq on the
rocks
you know by the grace of god i'm so
blessed i got so many guys who are
catching touchdowns wearing chains i got
trey lance throwing touchdowns wearing
chains you watch the game you watch the
game with your family your friends and
someone's like hey you know that guy's
wearing jewelry in the back of your head
you're like yeah i know i made it
[Music]
killing bro i'm just at a gq on the
rocks
got this right here
yeah
yeah
yes sir so justin jefferson called me
when he was about to go to the draft and
he was like hey bro i need i need a jet
piece so we went through a couple
designs at first at frost and co we hand
draw all our designs
it's a really unique process about
going through like maybe five six seven
designs and eventually we came to an
idea where
why don't we make an infinity cuban link
we'll put stars going through it we'll
make it two-toned rose and white gold
and we'll make the jet white gold it'll
make it really pop and this is all
actually one piece it's not detachable
it costs a hundred thousand justin
jefferson's the kind of guy where he's
not going to buy a lot of jewelry he
wants a nice piece that he can have for
a very long time
see how this controller chain was
definitely definitely one of the longest
projects i've ever worked on this piece
took about two months to make over 300
grams of gold 80 carats of diamonds this
is a heavy hitter when i met pat his
nickname was
pabst certains the second i saw in his
bio it said ps2 for the draft knight
we were like yo let's make a ps2
controller these analog sticks actually
move the buttons are really cool because
this thing lights up
this is what
people would call a piece that just has
no budget this piece overall was 150
000.
[Music]
azizo gelari's piece he plays for the
new york giants
he wanted a piece that could really
reflect who he is who
he would want to be people don't really
do black diamonds it's not something
that people are getting every day
and it's the black panzer so you have to
do it in black diamonds uh we've got the
white diamonds going through the piece
and we added a black cuban link around
it it comes with a bracelet set right
here too and this piece actually glows
in the dark if you turn the lights off
this thing will glow
[Music]
this jesus piece was made for my man
tristan thompson he hit me up and he was
like hey leo
i want a black jesus
show me what you can do i made the
rosary links right here they've got
barrel links on the chain actually each
one of these spears right here weighs
about like 15 grams this uh chain itself
weighs 200 grams it's got over 50 carats
of diamonds this piece costs
92 000. we added green links on the
sides he plays with the celtics
we thought it would be a cool theme
if he goes to a different team we'll
probably change the color tristan lets
me work with bigger budgets he lets me
show the world what i can do thank you
tristan
this right here
jayla waddle if you're watching this
you're my dog jaylen wado is from a-leaf
a-leaf is
a big part of houston's culture a-leaf
is where the most nfl guys in the entire
country come from so we put in the
middle of this a right here we put the
apple for ailey from where he's from and
we spelled out wattle but the different
thing about this is a lot of people what
they do they'll have the double plate
like this but all the diamonds would be
the same size jalen waddle is a little
different so we have to put a little
more respect on his name and we put 10
pointers on all the letters so he's got
big stones going across the letters and
he's got this j up here so it's jalen
waddle from egg leaf
this is called a glass house this piece
is from markelle fultz nba player right
here these are all emerald cuts on the
piece they go all the way around and
then on the sides we put round diamonds
got a very very clean sharp look for
markel he's got his logo the m
and the f emerald cuts are harder to set
but if you do them right you do them
with me
it makes sense when you have an
operation this big you're not setting
all the diamonds yourself you have
diamond setters i've got some of the
best diamond setters in the world if you
look at my pieces you'll never find any
bumps you'll never find any cracks
it's set really tight and the tighter
the setting the better the piece the
better the quality you're paying for
what you get
right here my main man jamar chase this
is a ftf pendant he likes to have this
unique baguette look so we put baguettes
all the way around it round diamonds in
the middle highlighted the ftf in the
middle
right here i made a piece for patrick
queen this is a level up piece when he
went to the nfl draft he was like leo
my life is all about leveling up i'm
leveling up right now i need a cool
chain i made this one right here for
andrew thomas uh it's a grizzly bear
andrew thomas is big on that he feels
like he's fierce so he gets a grizzly
bear this right here is for javon kinlaw
he doesn't like having big flashy
jewelry he just likes the cool small
stuff this is a jesus with emerald cuts
on the back of it most people have
baguettes emerald cuts is like the next
step but emerald cuts cost more bigger
budget better quality
if you got the money it costs a frost
what a lot of jewelers won't do is they
won't show you their work unfinished
it's either because they don't make it
themselves
or they're just too scared to show you i
don't know if you all like anime i'm
kind of a nerd sometimes now if you've
ever watched naruto
and you know a guy named kakashi kakashi
is the sensei and christian bar more
called me and he was like yo
i am the sensei i need the kakashi piece
i said all right there's baguettes going
through this right here and then on the
whole piece is actually round diamonds
now what you're looking at this is a
white gold it hasn't been polished it
hasn't even been touched it hasn't even
been soldered i'm pulling the head off
right now
once all this gets done it'll be enamel
work all the way through the hair will
be enameled the bandana will be enameled
all the way through even the shoes
so it's really about bringing a piece to
life this will look like the actual
cartoon character when it's done and
i'll send you pics
this right here
is just a different style of cuban this
is a gucci link but then just put
baguettes all through them something
like this goes for around 25 000.
very chilled two-toned this right here
is your classic baguette chain a lot of
people rocking tennis chains a lot of
people like the round diamonds and stuff
those are cool
but when you have something like this
it's a little different more people are
looking you can never go wrong with the
miami cuban this is the classic favorite
chain these sell like hotcakes because
these retain the most value jewelry is
about buying like cool stuff but also
investing you buy a cuban link
and you buy it for me quality nice it's
all about investing it's cool this right
here is a gold presidential standard
gentleman's watch if you got a meeting
going on you're about to go into a
boxing ring and you got media day before
this is the kind of watch you want right
here i've got the cartier santos it's a
two tone with the big boy bezel and it's
made with an arabic dial it's got all
sexy stones in it very clean i love this
watch it's probably the hottest selling
watch of 2020 2021. i'm just gonna wear
this for the rest of the show i've got
another cartier santos
arabic dial this is for my boy isaiah
stewart from the detroit pistons he's
coming to pick this watch up this
weekend something like this goes for 23
000.
and this right here is your starter kit
obviously it's a rolex datejust everyone
in the game when they get some money it
becomes
you know let's start off with a role
like state just and something like this
you start at 24 000
real chill
there's a strong misconception that
athletes don't know how to spend their
money
they're just buying all this stupid
stuff when you come from where most
these athletes come from
they don't have a lot growing up this
right here is a is a trophy it shows you
and symbolizes like look i've made it
why can i not buy something like this
it's all about being the best version of
yourself and being happy and that's how
you ball out on and off the field shout
out gq appreciate you all stopping by
thank you for diving into my world i
feel humbled to be part of this and
thank you for highlighting my life